new tournament fighter yeah impressive  breasts physics yeah they've got a nice  jiggle on mother curvier fighters - how  does the game play  I don't know I turn it on and the  opening cinematic starts I get  hypnotized and then it just goes into  demo mode and I can't stop watching the  gameplay and fighters this you know  heavy always suck usually that's the  price of innovation how you figure well  it's like porn  you don't expect oscar caliber acting  just straight titillations you trade  acting for boobs you're doing the same  here with the gameplay don't know if I'd  go so far as to compare it to porn okay  maybe that move possibly her victory  pose hey guys what the hell is you doing  my god Becca why are her breasts  bouncing independently of each other  when she's not even moving